- Hi everyone. Good evening.
My name is Priya Natarajan.
I am an astrophysicist
and the current director
of Yale's Franke Program in
Science and the Humanities.
I am delighted to have
you all, to welcome you
to today's wonderful talk
titled White Gold Fever,
The Story of Deep Sea Treasure
and an Environmental Tragedy
by the Esteemed Journalist Esther Honig.
Before I start giving you
a brief bio of Esther's,
I would like to recognize our benefactors,
Mr. And Mrs. Richard and Barbara Franke,
whose support for interdisciplinary
scholarship at Yale
has made this and many other
ventures around Yale possible.
In particular, I give out a warm shout out
to Barbara Franke, who
is in the audience today.
And as part of my required duties,
let me also remind you that
for those of us who are assembled,
that we are recording this
event and that all participants
will therefore have to
have their videos muted
for the duration of the talk.
Questions may be submitted at
any time to the Q&A feature,
and we will have dedicated Q&A session
after Esther's talk.
So let me tell you a little bit more
about this fascinating author.
Esther works both in print
and audio to create stories
that are at the focus of the
intersection of agriculture,
immigration, and climate change.
A perfect fit to the
interdisciplinary nature
of the activities at Frankie.
She's a fluent Spanish speaker
with a degree in Spanish
and Latin American studies,
and she travels to
Mexico and across the US
to carry out her reporting.
She's an incredible storyteller,
as you'll all see very shortly.
Her work has been published
by The Nation, Snap Judgment,
Latino USA, National Public
Radio, and much more.
Her piece for Mother Jones Magazine
about the spread of COVID-19
inside Midwestern meat
packing plants was cited
by US Senators in a letter
confronting corporate executives.
So she also not only tells stories,
but stories that make us
understand accountability.
Accountability to each other,
accountability to the earth,
accountability to climate change.
She's the recipient of the
UC Berkeley's 11th Hour
Food and Farming Fellowship,
and her work has been recognized
by the Edward R Murrow Award
and the Society for
Professional Journalists.
She has been invited to present her work
at tons of conferences and universities.
She cut her teeth as a reporter
working for public radio
stations across the country
where she covered everything
from the opioid epidemic
to impacts of Trump's
immigration policies.
These days, Esther noted
that she prefers to work on
in depth narrative driven
stories that stray as far away
as possible from the grind
of the immediate daily news.
So before I turn over to
Esther for this evening,
let me just mention our
Learning by Doing Project.
Please consider contributing
simple science experiments
that you can do at home for kids
to our website, little videos.
Take a look at our website
to see how to do that.
And I also want to advertise
our event as part of the
Understanding the Nature of
Inference colloquium series.
We have our virtual talk by
Professor Brian Cantwell-Smith,
which is on Wednesday, December 7th,
and a discussion session on
the eighth, both at 3:00 PM.
Anyway, without further ado,
I would like to turn the
floor over to Esther Honig.
Thank you so much, Esther, for coming.
We're absolutely delighted and
cannot wait to hear from you.
- Thank you so much. That was
such a lovely introduction.
I'm so excited to be here today
and share this story with you.
This took many months.
It was part of a strong team
of editors and producers
at Snap Judgment.
And without further ado,
we're just gonna jump into
it and I'm gonna share
this story that I love
so much with you all.
So I'm gonna share my screen.
All right, White Gold Fever,
Story of Deep Sea Treasure
and Environmental Tragedy.
So our story begins,
this is Belen Delgado,
and he's the protagonist of our story.
He first learned to fish at the age of 10,
and he's been doing this all his life.
And I'm just gonna
start off by playing you
the opening cut of tape from my story.
(waves crashing)
(Belen speaking Spanish)
(waves crash)
- [Esther] Standing on an
empty beach covered in fog,
Belen Delgado points to
an area on the horizon
where 15 years ago he found something
that would change his life
and the lives of everyone he knew.
- [Translator] Well, the truth is,
it was one of the best chapters of my life
for my family, for my town.
(Belen speaking Spanish)
(waves crashing)
- All right, I hope that helped everyone
get a little transported into this story.
That's why I love working
with audio so much.
So this is Teacapan, we
have right here on the map,
and that's where our story
takes place 15 years ago.
This is a fishing town
of about 4,000 people
located in Sinaloa, Mexico
at the most southern point of the state.
It is such a small town, there's
not a single traffic light.
There's no grocery store.
There's one or two paved
roads in the entire town.
So this is a fishing town.
Even on the entrance to the town,
there's a big archway and it says,
Teacapan, Town of Fishermen.
Every day at the beach,
there are fishermen arriving from their,
every morning at the beach,
there are fishermen
arriving with their catch
from the night before.
They're fishing mackerel,
sea bass, stingray, shark.
They even used to fish sea turtle
back when it was still legal.
And everything here, the
culture, the daily life,
the traditions, it all
circulates around fishing.
So this again, is a catch
that was brought in from the ocean.
Fishermen spend the
whole night working out
on the open ocean catching
fish to bring into the market.
This man right here is
holding mackerel, or sierra,
and this is the preferred
fish for making ceviche.
Sinaloa is known for its ceviche,
but this town, it is seafood and ceviche.
I mean, it's at every
party, for breakfast,
you eat fried fish.
It is, seafood and fish is your breakfast,
lunch, and dinner.
And even the food itself,
the way that they prepare
the ceviche's unlike anything
that I've seen in other
parts of the state.
Like again, just to show you
that it's just such a big part
of this town.
You'll be walking down the street
and you'll run into
someone like this fisherman
who's repairing his net.
It's just everywhere that you look.
This is a shrine for St. Andrew.
He's the patron saint of fisherman.
And the shrine is right,
it's overlooking the dock
where fishermen leave at dusk
to spend the night out on the ocean
so they can stop here first
and pray for protection.
So our story begins here in this town,
and it's 15 years ago,
and they're going through
a particularly bad spell.
There's been rampant
over fishing in the area,
and suddenly the populations
of shrimp, of fish
are starting to drop off.
Many of the fishermen are
struggling to make a living,
keep food on the table.
There are families who are growing hungry,
who are going hungry,
and no one really knows
what's happened to the fish.
They just know that they're gone.
(Belen speaking Spanish)
- [Translator] We'd
send people out to fish
and they wouldn't bring back anything.
In fact, many would say, what's going on?
And it's like, well, who
knows? There aren't any fish.
There's nothing.
- It's getting so bad, the
local businesses are closing.
People are even trying to
sell their fishing boats.
But of course no one wants to buy them.
And so one evening, Belen is sitting out
in front of his house with his old friend,
he's also a fisherman.
And they're talking
after a long day at work.
And that's when Belen decides
he's gonna share a bit of
gossip that he heard that day.
And it was from a guy who
works on the shrimping boats.
Now, these are bigger boats
and they have large nets,
trawling nets that they
drop into the ocean,
they scrape along the ocean
floor and they bring up shrimp.
And earlier that day,
this man had been working
on the shrimping boat.
They dropped their nets
in like they always do.
They pull them back up and
when they pull up the net,
they discovered something
caught in the webbing
that was beyond shocking.
(Belen speaking Spanish)
- [Translator] One, and then another
callo de hacha fell out.
(Belen speaking Spanish)
El callo, it's one of those species that,
let's put it this way,
it's one of the most expensive
things you can catch.
(Belen speaking Spanish)
- All right, this is the callo de hacha.
callo means scallop, and
hacha translates to hatchet,
and it gets that name for
the shape of its shell,
which looks like a hatchet.
So over here you have one that is open,
you have the entrails,
and then right here you have
this coin of white meat.
And that is the part that's consumed.
That usually eaten raw,
and it is considered a delicacy.
I also understand that it's
native to the Sea of Cortez,
and this is a product
that, it's a delicacy.
It's sold to high end restaurants
all along the coast in Mexico.
It's also shipped out to Mexico City
where it's sold, again, in
very upscale restaurants.
And as Belen reiterates,
this is one of the most expensive things
you can possibly find in their oceans.
So no one had ever
caught this type of callo
in Teacapan before.
And they're a little bit
shocked by this story
that a callo has appeared
in a shrimping net.
Then the following week when
a shrimping boat catches
another callo, they bring it to Belen,
and that's when he
starts to get a big idea.
Belen, who went to college
for fisheries biology,
he knows that this isn't
just a coincidence.
Typically, callo, were
jammed between rocks.
And so when you harvest them,
you have to kind of cut them out,
de-lodge them, if you will,
from the crevasse where
they've been living.
So the mere fact that they've
been swept up in this net
tells Belen that there are so many of them
piled on the ocean floor,
that they can be easily collected
or cut loose by the gentle
tug of one of these nets.
So he's starting to imagine
that there is a pile of callo
lurking beneath the ocean water.
And that's when he starts to make a plan.
So here, Teacapan, from
the satellite imagery.
Here, this snaking river is the estuary,
and that's what lent this town
to being a town of fishermen.
That's what it is founded for,
is because it was such a
great location for fishing.
And it is in large part
because of this estuary.
So right here off of the
mouth of the estuary,
you have Playa La Tambora.
So that is, it's right around here
that this shrimping boat is going down
and catching these callo and it's net.
And so Belen decides,
that what they need to do
is they have to get a scuba diver.
Because this is deeper
than any of them can go.
It's about 80 feet below the surface.
No one had the equipment or
the knowhow to dive that far.
So he goes to the local, a
nearby city of Escuinapa,
about 45 minutes away,
they don't find anything.
They drive two hours away to
the larger city of Mazatlan
and they still, they
can't find the equipment,
they can't find anyone
who's able to do this.
And then finally, Belen calls up a friend
in Baja, California, we're
diving is more common.
Fishermen make a living this way
by going down into the ocean
and harvesting big mollusks
and things like callo.
And he gets a guy, a diver, on the phone
and he gets him to agree to come down.
(Belen speaking Spanish)
- [Translator] We asked him,
how much will you charge us
to do this job?
And he said, how about we make a deal?
If there's callo I won't
charge you for the trip,
but you'll give me a
chance to fish some of it.
If there's nothing, you'll pay
for my trip there and back.
- [Belen] Okay, Esta bien.
- [Translator] So he came.
- [Esther] But also wanted
to keep this a secret.
(Belen speaking Spanish)
- [Translator] Let's be discreet
so that this doesn't
turn into complete chaos.
Everything must be done carefully.
I said, you know what?
If there are callo, don't tell anyone.
(Belen speaking Spanish)
- Okay? So they have a bit
of an agreement going on.
The diver comes down, they
take him out to an area,
more or less around here.
They get his equipment
on the boat, they go out,
he puts on his white fisherman boots
and he revs up his air compressor.
So no one is diving
here with an oxygen tank
because that's far too expensive.
And I'm gonna show you
what that looks like
in just a minute.
Using an air compressor is
the preferred means of diving,
and it's also very dangerous.
So the diver puts on a lead belt,
which helps him sink to the bottom.
He flops over the side of the boat
and he sinks to the bottom of the ocean.
And about an hour passes,
Belen, his friend,
his brother-in-law, they're
all on the boat just waiting
to see what he returns with.
(Belen speaking Spanish)
- [Translator] And when the diver came up,
the surprise he had, 100 pounds of callo.
I said to him, what did
it look like down there?
You all are sitting on a mine of gold.
He says, wherever you step, there's callo.
(Belen speaking Spanish)
- [Translator] Oh, dear God.
- So the men had assembled
upon a massive colony
of shellfish just off the town shore.
And this is equivalent to finding
something like sunken treasure.
Researchers would later
determine that it covered
a stretch of ocean floor,
about 35 miles long and a mile wide,
looked something like this.
And the estimated value was
somewhere around $2 million.
So the next day, Belen gets in his truck
and he drives two hours away to Mazatlan
to go to this big government building
where the federal fishing
authorities are housed.
It's called Conapesca.
And he gets a meeting
with one of the higher ups
and he tries to explain his situation.
To prove what he's found, he has a cooler
full of his shellfish, of the callo.
'Cause he needs them to believe him.
And he explains what he wants.
He wants there to be permits
for all the fishermen
in his town so that callo can
be caught and sold legally.
And he also knows
that there needs to be
some sort of regulation.
They need to have a quota system
because if there isn't
some sort of intervention,
this is gonna be immediately over-fished.
He is aware of just how desperate
the men in his town are,
because remember, they're
coming off of the last few years
of very, very bad fishing levels.
So this is important that
it be controlled somehow.
And he's basically begging
this agent to come in and help.
And the agent says, yeah, you know,
we'll see what we can do.
Belen leaves feeling like,
okay, I've done the right thing,
I've gotten the ball rolling.
Meanwhile, back in Teacapan,
unfortunately the scuba diver from Baja
is out there catching callo
because that was the
agreement that they had.
And the people in Teacapan
can see him from the shore.
It's so close.
And they see this guy, a
scuba diver, diving in,
coming up a little bit while later.
And they get curious.
There's always, Belen says,
there's always a lot of
gossip between the fishermen.
So someone eventually gets in their boat
and they scuttle over
to see what is going on.
And they see all of these
big bags of callo de hacha
sitting in the boat and it's
like a bomb goes off, right?
This guy goes back to town,
he tells everyone what he's just seen,
word is out and mayhem ensues.
To quote myself from my story,
almost immediately, everyone in the town,
some of whom had never
fished before in their lives,
teachers, politicians, ranchers,
bought boats and hired divers.
And men who didn't know how to dive
were signing up for the job.
There was money to be made
and everyone wanted in.
Oh, sorry.
Nope.
I might be missing a piece
of audio. That's okay.
Yes. Okay,
So there's this piece of
audio that I wanted to share,
and the Belen is, I'll
just read it for you.
There was a doctor, a good
friend of the fisherman,
he bought three boats.
He didn't even need the money.
It made me so mad, so angry
to see this type of person
take advantage and they
could give a damn, right?
So this piece of audio really, I feel,
illustrates this question that
we're starting to confront,
which is who does this belong to?
In Belen's mind and the fisherman's mind,
they've dedicated their
whole lives to this trade.
And now that there's this opportunity
to make a lot of money,
they fully believe that
this is rightfully theirs.
Of course, this is a natural resource.
There is no intervention from
authorities at this point.
No one is saying who can
and cannot harvest callo.
And so people are being
opportunistic and is often the case.
The rich are getting richer.
Now, one positive aspect to
the discovery of the callo,
of everyone going out and fishing callo,
is that very suddenly there's
a ton of money in this town.
It is exploding with earnings.
People who are just
making $10 before, a day,
are now making a hundred to even $150.
That is the price that this
shellfish is earning them
on the market.
In a town where shops are closing,
now they're living in this moment of glory
and things are being revived,
shops are being reopened.
Everyone is looking for any
excuse they can to party.
(Belen speaking Spanish)
- [Translator] Let's just
say there was a lot of money.
People bought cars and as
much beer as they wanted,
they had big weddings and parties.
If they saw you walking by,
they'd just offer you a
plate of callo de hacha
which is something that we never ate.
And now we could eat all we wanted.
(Belen speaking Spanish)
We felt proud.
We felt really important
because during this time,
the economy of the Teacapan,
I tell you, grew by 1000%.
(Belen speaking Spanish)
- [Esther] Belen Started fishing too.
Now, something that I
thought was really important
while writing this story is
that had it been told from the,
had it not been told from the
perspective of the fishermen,
like in any sort of traditional article,
they might have described
the fishermen as the villains
and the callo as the prey.
And what I wanted to do was
show that these are families,
these are human beings and their parents
and for that matter,
they're, like most of us,
interested in improving their lot in life.
Yes, there were parties
and there were bad actors
who were exploiting the situation,
but because of this money,
people are able to do things
they could have never imagined.
Like put their children
through college or buy a car
that they could later
use to start a business
or install running water in their homes.
And so I often think when
we observe these situations,
things like poaching or the exploitation
of natural resources,
and we're standing at this position
of immense economic privilege.
And I say that as someone who
lives in the United States,
and we have a tendency to
sympathize with the animals
that are being extracted or hunted.
And I wanted to show that
I believe these communities
of people also deserve our empathy.
These are people, many of
whom are living hand to mouth,
truly on in many cases
the brink of survival.
And so yes, we may see them as greedy,
but it is not entirely
that black and white.
There is nuance here.
So a few weeks go by since
the callo have been discovered
and the news has spread.
People are coming from across
the state to fish callo.
And then the news catches on
and reporters have come to town
and they love this story
of like the Cinderella town
that was down on their luck
and now suddenly is exploding
with opportunity and money.
The headlines are things
like the Cocaine of the Sea
is what they're calling it.
Another one is of course white gold fever,
which became the title for this piece.
And I found this clip from Mundo Vision
and they did like a long segment on it.
This was not just local
news, this was national.
When it first broke, this was a big deal
and people were really
excited and interested
in seeing what was happening.
So I just wanted to show this to you
because we can actually
see the folks diving.
(light music)
Now, this is entirely in Spanish,
so I'm just gonna narrate a little bit.
I just wanted to show people a little bit
of what we're seeing just in terms of
like the talent itself.
These are guys getting ready
to go fishing for the day
to go catch some callo.
This of course is the
fisherman that the reporter
is shadowing and he's explaining,
they're all gonna drive up about
or boat up about 25 minutes
to where this giant bank of
callo has been discovered.
I'm gonna fast forward a little bit, okay,
here we're gonna see the diving.
Okay, so as I mentioned,
we do not use, this is not a oxygen tank.
That tube right there
is what's connected to the air compressor
that is forcing oxygen through that tube
that then goes into the divers mask.
That is an air compressor
that's run off the gasoline, right?
This is pretty rudimentary.
Here we have our diver
and he's talking about
some of the dangers that are inherent
with using this machine.
The tube can get tied up,
sometimes it can break.
If the machine breaks while
the divers under water,
they have to be careful, they
can't come up too quickly.
They'll get the bends, very dangerous.
See that's his lead belt.
And you see that he's wearing
jeans and fishing boots.
And I think this part is so cool
because the cameramen
actually went down with him
or they brought a camera
down there so we could see.
Now you'll see he's holding
a rope in his hands.
And that is el cabo de vita.
So the fishermen who are
waiting up top, in that boat,
you see it?
They're waiting to see if they feel a tug.
If he feels two tugs,
that means that the dive
is ready to come back up.
And they'll pull that rope and
they'll deliver him back up.
If it's one tug, there's
something that's gone wrong,
something has happened on the ocean floor
and he needs help now.
And that is the extent
of their communication.
So as you can imagine,
incredibly risky, very dangerous.
And this is how all of this
callo is being extracted,
not just at this moment Teacapan,
but this is pretty widespread
across all of Mexico.
So it's been okay.
It's been about four months
since the callo were found.
And now the amount of boats
that are out on the water
has more than tripled.
There are about 300 boats
out there on a daily basis,
and they're all harvesting
around a hundred to 200 pounds
a day of pure callo meat.
So not even counting the shells.
And this entire time
Belen has been fishing
under a self-imposed quota.
He thinks that he needs to set an example
for the other fishermen
because this is the
responsible thing to do.
He owns four fishing boats
and he has fishermen who
go out and fish for him.
And he is only gonna send in two.
And this is his way of
sort of demonstrating
that we can control ourselves.
We don't have to fish
this into extinction.
So at around that time,
a local university comes
and they perform a study
of the callo population.
They hold a meeting for
all of the fishermen
out on the boardwalk,
and they tell them that this
bank of callo is so large,
it can last 10 years.
Other sources claim it
could have lasted as long
as 30 years, but they have
to fish it sustainably.
That means limiting how much is harvested,
so that the population it can reproduce.
And this is Belen, he feel like,
he feels like he's found his moment
and he stands up and he talks to everyone.
(Belen speaking Spanish)
- [Translator] Gentleman,
we have to take care
of the shellfish.
We have to ration how much we catch.
What do we gain by
fishing 200 pounds each?
If they're not going to
give us a good price,
let's only fish 100 pounds per boat,
so they pay us a higher price
and the callo will last longer.
(Belen speaking Spanish)
- So understands they
cannot keep extracting callo
at the current rate.
And in no time at all,
they're gonna be back
to where they were before
with nothing left to fish.
He also knows that they're
flooding the market with callo,
and that's driving the price down.
It's now at about half of what it was
when they originally started out.
And he wants everyone
to abide by this quota.
And he knows it can work
because in other communities in Mexico,
fishermen preserve the fish populations
by fishing under these
self-imposed quotas.
He knows it can work, but the fishermen,
they don't seem to believe him.
Perhaps they don't believe that
the callo will ever run out.
Maybe they think, maybe they're so happy
that they don't wanna admit
that this euphoric chapter
of fishing will eventually end.
And I think in many ways
it also speaks as something
that Belen shares, which is
the mentality of the fishermen.
And that is that you have to fish today
because you don't know
if you're gonna be able
to fish tomorrow.
So this sort of survival mentality,
short term thinking is
really what he's up against
in trying to convince them
to change their approach.
So after about six months,
the authorities have finally
managed to issue licenses
for the fishermen.
And they've told them
that they're on their own
to regulate themselves.
It turns out that Conapesca,
the agency that the
went to at the beginning
is such a rigid, large government agency
that in order to do things
like issue, to enforce quotas,
they have to perform multiple studies.
It's like there's so many
levels of bureaucratic red tape.
The system just isn't designed to protect
this sort of one-off discovery.
It's designed to protect populations
that we already know exist, right?
There's the fishing licenses.
There are patrols by
people who are essentially wildlife,
I don't wanna say police officers, but,
there are people, agents
who are there to make sure
that everyone is following the rules.
There is that system in place,
but it's not able to be nimble enough
to come in last minute and try
and protect something before,
just as it's been discovered
before it's completely wiped out.
So as more callo is
fished out of this bank
that we saw off the coast of Teacapan,
the divers are having to
actually go deeper and deeper
to continue to extract callo.
And as they go deeper and deeper,
they're also spending far
longer on the ocean floor
and they're getting the bends.
There are also issues, like I
mentioned with the equipment.
There are pipes or there
are tubes that explode.
And what the result is
that seven divers die
because there is not a hyperbaric
chamber in Teacapan right?
They just have a tiny little clinic.
And the closest hyperbaric chamber,
which is used to treat the
bends, is two hours away.
And in one instance, Belen,
one of his divers gets sick
and he calls an ambulance
and they agreed to meet him halfway.
So, he gets the diver in his truck,
they race as fast as they
can to the halfway point
of Escuinapa and when he gets there,
the ambulance is waiting
and they hoist him
into the ambulance and he takes off
and he gets to Mazatlan in time.
He's able to get a hyperbaric
into a hyperbaric chamber
and his life is saved.
But there's just so many people
who were not as fortunate.
And you know,
I think I can imagine that
there are probably some folks
in the group, perhaps
professionally trained divers,
thinking, 'wow, how stupid were people,
what were they thinking
doing this sort of work?'
And for me it really highlights
the level of desperation,
just how far people were willing to go
in order to have a shot
at a decent living, right?
They're putting everything on the line.
They may not know how to dive properly.
They may not have a clue that there's
a specific limit to how
long they should be down
on the ocean floor.
All they know is that this is their chance
to earn money for themselves and perhaps
their families as well.
So at this point, nothing
can stop the onslaught.
People are dying.
Belen has tried to entice
the fishermen to fish less
by giving them better
prices for their catch.
Nothing works, no one
is willing to relent.
And this is when it becomes
a race to the bottom.
Because when you hold back on your catch,
but you know your neighbor
is just gonna go out and fish
that portion anyway, why would you comply?
And eventually even Belen gives up.
He sends out all his boats
and decides that he'll reap
as much benefit as he's able to
because down the line he knows
that just like everyone else,
he's gonna be completely screwed.
He might as well enjoy
this moment while he can,
earn what he can before it's gone
because they're all gonna
have to kind of suffer through
the reality afterwards of being left
without anything to fish.
And so we're now finally arriving
at the end of the story of callo de hacha.
Nearly a year and a half, nearly sorry,
less than a year since
they were discovered.
Now there are so many
shells and callo guts
that the fishermen have
been carelessly tossing
over their boats as they
harvest and clean the callo
that that's polluted the water.
And it's ruined this ecosystem
that allowed the callo to
thrive down there for decades.
This causes a mass die off
and the last callo to be
extracted or fished out
are already dead.
So we're at the end of our story.
Today, Teacapan is nearly,
the fishing in Teacapan
is nearly at an end.
Over fishing and climate change
has really brought the
industry to its knees.
And the young people
don't follow their parents
into this work anymore because
they know it's grueling
and it can't really provide a living.
Most people, including the Belen's kids,
have left the town for work in the city
or even in the United States.
So if my small presentation
has peaked your interest,
I just wanna point you all
towards the full story,
which you can hear on Snap Judgment.
The episode's called Mother Nature.
And I wanna give a brief shout out
to the Food and Environment
Reporting Network
where I'm a contributing
writer and they fund reporting
that focuses on agriculture
and environment.
And without their support,
this story would not have been possible.
And now I just wanna pivot a
little bit and talk a bit about
what I do as an agricultural journalist.
So I have spent the last
few years telling everyone
that I am not a science journalist
and yet I keep getting invited
to speak at science events.
And I think this comes from
a place of my own insecurity,
mainly because my stories,
and if you listen to them or read them,
are not often chocked full
of data analytics and graphs.
I am horrible at math
and I might not even
directly quote a scientist
in the work that I do because
I think it's so important
to keep the workers or the producers
at the center of my stories.
But I'm starting to
notice a sort of shift.
I've been cultivating this
beat for the last several years
and I often say that I
report on the intersection
of agriculture and immigration.
And we're talking about farm workers,
like you see in this photo,
we're talking about meat packing workers
and fishermen like Belen.
But now I'm starting to think
that I need to change that
to say the intersection of
agriculture and climate change.
Now, more than ever,
the impacts of climate change
are increasingly relevant
to my reporting because these
are the people who are living
on the front lines of this crisis.
As the temperatures
rise, not only will this,
will our food be impacted,
but more importantly will impact
the people who produce it.
So in this photo here,
we have migrant workers
who are harvesting lettuce
in Yuma, Arizona.
They cross the border every day
from Mexico to do this work.
And in the fall in Yuma,
average temperatures
are around 102 degrees,
which is the start of lettuce season.
And on average, a US farm
worker endures 21 unsafe days
during the growing season.
And by mid-century that's
set to increase to 39 days.
And we are already seeing harrowing news
of farm workers dying from heat stroke
in places you might not expect
like Washington and Oregon.
So this is very rapidly becoming
one of the top concerns.
And we see this too in
places like Teacapan,
how climate change is impacting them.
Warming waters mean
that the schools of fish
that these fishermen rely
on are seeking cooler waters
out in the open ocean.
So you'll remember I
showed you those photos
of folks coming back in the morning
from having spent the
the night out fishing.
So this means that the fishermen
must now travel further
in order to catch their fish.
And that costs them more
in gasoline to get there.
It also means that their work
is becoming increasingly dangerous.
They're out there at night
because schools of fish
tend to be more active under moonlight.
And yeah, this is all just combined
to make their job more expensive,
more dangerous, more grueling.
And even if we zoom back to an even larger
and take a more macro
perspective on this intersection
of climate change and agriculture.
I just wanna point out
that the many people
who have gathered in migrant camps
along the US Mexico border,
folks who are hoping to seek
asylum in the United States,
many of these people are former farmers.
They were driven from their
lands due to climate change,
due to underproduction of their crops
due to unreliable rains
and weather patterns.
And they moved to cities and in the cities
they were vulnerable to
things like extortion
and gang violence.
And so from there sought refuge north.
So it's all very, very interconnected.
I think a lot of times when I tell people
that I report on agriculture,
I get a lot of blank
stares and I admit that
even to me it sounds a bit boring.
But when we start to see our world
through this perspective of food systems
and who produces our food,
I think it's really fascinating.
And it can tell you so
much about our politics,
our own sense of empathy,
and even our understanding of science.
And in our current generation,
I think this is going to become
one of the most important
topics of our time, our farm workers
and climate change,
food system and climate change.
I'm gonna just leave my
presentation real quick
'cause I wanna make sure
we have time for a video.
Belen was not able to join us here.
He does not have a very
reliable internet connection.
This is also the day that
his sons are coming back
from the US after a very long stint
working on a farm in Washington.
They've been there for nine months.
But I did wanna be able to include him
in this presentation somehow.
So the folks at the Franke
program were very generous
and helped me to put
subtitles to a quick interview
that I did with him via video.
And I've asked him what does
he hope comes from this story
being published and out there
and what does he believe
that the fisherman have learned
from the callo de hacha.
(speaking Spanish)
- But I just wanna finish up
with pointing out some of the,
a little bit of the different
style that I work in,
which is narrative storytelling
and how that can overlap
with science to make it more powerful.
So you, listening to my story,
if you have the opportunity might notice
there's not a whole lot of science there
in terms of numbers and terminology.
And I worked with a
really brilliant editor,
her name is Nancy Lopez,
and she really worked
with me to kind of trim
all of that out because she, like I,
really believe in the
power of a good story.
Unlike a traditional news article,
these stories have
beginning middles and ends.
They have a narrative arc.
They have a character we
follow on their journey
and maybe they can overcome
the challenges they face.
Maybe they can slay the
dragon or maybe they can't,
maybe they can't stop all of the fishermen
from extracting this natural resource
before it's completely wiped out.
But the idea is that we
follow them on their journey
and we learn to empathize with them.
And I think it's such an important tool,
especially when we're
talking about climate change.
We've been so good at ignoring this crisis
for so many generations,
even with the science
really being right in front of our faces.
And I think it's because
it's a huge concept.
I think it's overwhelming.
And I think especially right now,
we find ourselves in these news cycles
that can be incredibly exhausting, right?
We open up the news in the morning
and there's so many stories
that immediately deserve our attention.
And I'm talking about the pandemic,
I'm talking about
democracy in this country,
a war raging in Europe.
There's so much to pay
attention to right now
in this age of information.
And so we really have to
work at how we can go about
getting this information, this notion
or getting people to care, to engage
when we are also overwhelmed
by the amount of information.
So I really look at a good story
as sort of this Trojan horse, if you will,
that we can tell a story
that is entertaining,
that is engaging,
that helps someone empathize with a person
on the other side of the world
in a completely different
socioeconomic status
and be able to empathize with them,
to see what it's like
to walk in their shoes
and to see what the impacts
of things like climate change,
or in this case overfishing,
really does to an individual
or to a community.
And so, when we, I think
we've learned to think about
these things separately
for a very long time.
As I mentioned,
I'm hesitant to say that
I'm a science journalist
or that my work is scientific in nature.
But when we start to
think about how science
and good storytelling
can be paired together,
I think we have the opportunity
to do something incredibly
powerful and immensely beautiful.
How can we tell these important stories
in a way that catches the
attention of audiences
that might not be able to,
might not want to listen otherwise?
I was just recently reminded
of this this morning,
there was actually some research from Yale
that was published talking about how folks
who are Republican have,
folks who identify as Republican
have a higher rate of death
from the COVID-19 disease.
And so you have to think, the
science is right there, right?
We all have seen the
science around COVID-19
and unless there is sometimes
there has to be a good
story to accompany that.
And some people there might be a bad story
that is telling people the wrong thing.
So, it's how do we
embrace this information?
How do we tell it through
a story that can do good
in this world who can get
people again to listen,
to get on board, to engage
as opposed to gloss over and as opposed to
take a story in a direction
that it shouldn't.
So I'm gonna stop sharing.
- Yeah, thank you so much Esther,
for such a fantastic talk
and explaining to us the multifaceted
and complex human interactions
and the sort of this
interweaving of nature
and human nature and the
decisions that we make
and the complexity of that process.
And you know,
science doesn't have
to be just about data.
Science really does, is done
in the larger human context.
And so I, I don't know,
I consider your story
to be deeply intertwined
with scientific concerns
and scientific questions.
So let me throw open
the floor for questions.
I don't see anything in the Q&A yet,
so please feel free to add
your questions in there.
- Thank you so much for
this entirely engrossing
and very tragic story.
And for telling it and bringing
this all to our attention
and a wider audience.
Ever the optimist, what are the prospects
for the callo coming back in this area
and what are Belen's thoughts
about what he, if he's around,
what he might do next time
or not do in that situation?
- Yeah, Belen is a big dreamer and he is,
I think after I talked
to his family about,
just asking some questions
about his character,
it turns out that he is ever the champion
of sustainable fishing.
And it comes to anything
from shrimp to sea bass.
He is there trying to mitigate issues
and ensure that everyone is
respecting this wildlife.
That's, I think, something very
near and dear to his heart.
And so, it's been 15 years,
since that callo bank was nearly wiped out
and it had probably sat
undisturbed for decades.
I don't know how long the estimates,
I'm not sure what they look like,
but who knows how long it
will take to grow back.
The fact is that it likely
will or that it already has
started to grow back and it's
sort of like poking the bear.
When do we make the decision
to get a diver out here
to bring them back down
to see what it looks like down there now.
Belen is very eager to do this.
He, I think because I took
an interest in this story,
really wants to explore it with me.
He wants to get a diver to come down.
He wants to see what's down there now
even though there have not
been any changes necessarily
to change what the
outcome would look like,
he believes that fishermen,
then the town have learned.
They learned their lesson,
they would never do that again.
And perhaps talking to him,
I really got the sense
that a lot of people
feel a lot of shame for what happened,
that they didn't act in time,
they didn't act appropriately.
And I think more than anything,
the death of those seven
divers really weighs on them.
And so there is an eagerness
to start it all again.
But there is also this belief
that perhaps they would be
able to regulate it themselves
and Belen is also very
much interested in the idea
of making it into some
sort of a farming system
so that these could be generated in a way
that I guess oysters are
to have always accessible
callo in cages in the ocean.
Something like that, that would
make this more long lasting.
- Thank you. We join him in his dream.
You can convey that to him, please.
Warm regards from Yale.
So from the audience,
thank you so much for this amazing talk.
I have a couple questions.
First, how did you come across this story?
And second, what advice do you
have for aspiring journalists
who want to do this kind of work?
- So I think I can
answer that in one swoop.
I have a relationship with
this town that dates back
to when I was in high school.
I was at a public high school,
one that really valued travel.
So instead of sports teams,
we did things like
language immersion trips.
And we had an exchange set up
with the school at Teacapan.
So I went down there when I was first 16,
I stayed with a host family.
I returned again my senior
year of high school.
And then just thanks to social media,
my host siblings were my age
and we continued to stay in touch.
I spent plenty of time in
Mexico studying Spanish.
So we were always able to
communicate pretty fluently.
And so that's how I
stumbled upon that story.
I was actually, that
story I actually heard
for the first time when
I was in high school.
And it was something that
just seemed so mystic
and so unbelievable that one day
just last year it occurred to
me that I could make a story
out of that.
That I had the resources,
that I now had the skills.
And of course I had those connections.
And I think for folks that
aspire to do this sort of work,
I mean obviously building
that skill set is important,
but the most important
thing is that innate sense
of curiosity and looking for
those stories in your own life,
Like what paths have
you crossed in your life
with What sorts of people?
What unbelievable stories do
you have in your back pocket
that you might tell friends and family
when you're all sitting down at dinner
or when you really wanna impress
someone with a good story.
What do you go back to?
What stories are already
a part of your life
that could be made into
something like a story,
an audio documentary.
And I think that a lot of us
have more of those stories
than we realize.
- So Esther, if I may use my prerogative
to ask you this question.
So Sinaloa is a complicated place, right?
Because isn't that the name
of one of the big drug cartels in Mexico?
- Yeah.
- I'm curious about how the larger culture
of that place kind of steeped with that.
How do you think that
impacted the thinking,
the way in which they
viewed commercialization?
- Yeah. Yeah, I can speak to some of that.
This was 15 years ago when
the callo were extracted,
so the situation was
different, absolutely.
Now Sinaloa is certainly
a state that's considered
very infiltrated and
controlled by the cartel.
And I would say that
absolutely extends to Teacapan
to an extent.
So you have things,
the sale of beer is controlled
by the cartel in that town.
At 8:00, the stores that sell
beer must close their doors.
And then the only stores
that are open that sell beer
are owned by the cartel.
So it's pervasive.
The folks part of this organization,
folks who are part of this
organized, criminal organization
are looking for any way to generate money.
- Incomes, multiple streams of money and..
- Exactly.
- That sort of ethics are not really
part of that discussion there.
- Right. So what's difficult, I think,
is that you're looking at a town
which subsisted for so long off of fishing
and now that source of
revenue for these families
is drying up and it's becoming harder.
So your kids either leave
to go somewhere else
or you're, unfortunately there.
You face the possibility
of working to some extent
with these organized gangs.
So I've heard things like
people using their boats
to transport drugs, really dangerous,
very dangerous stuff.
Even things like cartel
maybe fronting the money
for gasoline and taking
a cut of the profits
that you earn from fishing.
And so this highlights something
that's really important,
which is that not only is this
area already very unstable
politically in terms of
who controls this state,
it's very apparent that it is the cartels
and not necessarily the
government of Mexico.
But as things become more unstable
because of climate change,
people don't have a lot of other options.
For making a living
and I think we'll start
to see an increase in instability.
- Yeah, and I think you
made the point wonderfully
that finding sustainable options
is really, really challenging.
- Yeah, and Belen is a huge champion
of there being more shrimp farms,
there being packaging houses,
things that'll allow them to export,
to sell to markets directly.
All of this stuff is infrastructure
that if the fishermen had,
would allow them to possibly
sustain their way of life
to some degree.
There just isn't the upfront investment.
- Right, and also be
sort of more economically
self-sufficient in a way
and be more in control
of their destiny, right?
I mean, I think that's their dream.
That's what he's dreaming.
- Right, that's what they had,
they had that and then it was taken away.
A lot of that overfishing
comes from commercial fishing
fleets from foreign countries.
And of course we know
that low income countries
have not contributed to
climate change to the extent
that say America has.
- Yeah, I was just gonna
bring that point up
that I think your story is
very emblematic of the point
that the regions that are going
to actually feel the impact
of climate change, either directly
because of floods and
other natural disasters
or a shrinking of their
old ways of livelihood,
are sadly not the places
that have contributed
in a major way to the carbon
and to climate change and
the deleterious effects
of climate change, yeah.
So I really found that your
story was really beautiful
at sort of multiple levels.
So thank you once again for
this gorgeous study and book.
So we have a question from
Sylvia Peck in the audience.
Oh, sorry, I missed one
question prior to that.
The question is from one
of someone in the audience
who asked, I know you worked
in radio journalism for a while
earlier in your career.
How did you pivot to becoming a freelancer
and writing about agriculture?
- I actually began
writing about agriculture,
it was my beat as my last job
at a public radio station for NPR.
I was part of a regional collaborative
that contributed stories
across the country
to NPR about agriculture.
And I just found that I really loved it
and I really wanted to focus
on labor in agriculture specifically.
That had been a passion
of mine for a long time.
And what I found was that
I just got a little tired
of the NPR format as much
as I loved working for them,
I really wanted to be
able to do more long form
in depth stuff.
Things that really allow
characters to evolve
and allow for a bit more
flexibility and creativity.
And so I made the decision
to go freelance in 2019,
just a few months before the pandemic,
I quit my job and I moved to Mexico
and it had been a long
held dream of mine, right?
To do international work especially.
And so when it seemed that
the world was literally
just caving in on me,
'cause I had made this
risk during such really,
just bad timing.
It wound up actually
being fairly advantageous
because suddenly the topic
that I had now spent
three years cultivating,
this beat, was suddenly
on headlines nationally.
It became an immensely important issue
because we were,
for the first time a lot of
Americans were being forced
to contemplate where
their food comes from.
And if those people are sick,
they can't process it,
they can't harvest it.
And so in a way it was,
and I hate to say this,
but it was fortunate
that the timing was such.
And so I think those sorts
of elements have allowed me
to pick up a fairly
successful freelance career
from the beginning.
- Thanks, Esther. So an
insightful comment from Sylvia,
and we can build on it
and turn into a question.
She says she wanted to tell you
that she thinks you presented
this story beautifully.
I have to agree.
And she noticed that you
avoided making villains,
which in a Cinderella windfall
story might be tempting.
The benefit of your narrative
left us eager to learn more
and to feel included.
So maybe you could speak a bit to that.
How did you avoid that glaring temptation
to identify villains and protagonists?
- I think that honestly it was just trying
to follow the good story.
The good story is the hero
and he's the center of it.
And we're watching him step by step.
I think if there's a
villain in this story,
it's perhaps the regulatory
bodies of Mexico.
And as soon as that leaves my mouth,
I'm like immediately kind
of, it gets really boring.
And we all know,
we all know what that's
like for the most part.
That the regulations aren't working.
I feel like we can assume that is true,
not just perhaps in Mexico,
but other countries around the world.
And so I didn't really
wanna spend too much time
diving into that just because
I felt like it took away
from the story and I didn't wanna
also make this about the other
fishermen who are coming in.
There was a big issue towards the end,
what Belen called pirate fishermen
that were coming in at night
and they were fishing the callo
before any of the other
fishermen could get out there.
These were guys from far away.
And I also didn't feel like it
was fair to villainize them,
like just the fishermen
of Teacapan were very,
they were very adamant that
they weren't gonna stop people
from coming into their
town and fishing callo
because everyone is just trying to get by.
They're all in the struggles
together in a lot of ways.
And so if they weren't,
Belen can be angry at the
doctors and the ranchers
and the politicians who got boats
and went in and fish callo.
But I also feel that as a
reporter from the United States,
I honestly don't know if
their economic standing
is even much better perhaps than my own
if they're middle class in Mexico.
But, you know what I'm saying?
Like I don't think it's
fair as someone from my,
someone from my position to
necessarily villainize anyone
in this situation because I've been born
with so much opportunity
and relative wealth.
So I think it was just
checking my privilege honestly.
- Oh, but Esther, it's also
wonderful to hear the humility,
the place of humility and
learning that you have come from.
I think that makes the story,
it shines through in the story.
- [Esther] Well, thank you.
- As you can see, we are all gushy fans.
So are there any further
questions for Esther
before we close?
Ty, did you wanna have the final question?
- Where's your next story?
Not in Mexico. What are you working on?
- My next dream story is about
these canals in Mexico City,
that it's an area now called Xochimilco.
And these canals were what
originally the mechica,
or the indigenous community
that Cortez discovered
when he discovered Mexico,
were living then in Mexico City.
This is the area where they lived
and they had built these canals
and their whole city was a floating city.
Of course that's all been destroyed.
And so what's left is a
small region of the city
called Xochimilco where some
of these canals still exist.
And there is this wild
story from the seventies
when politicians in Mexico
wanted to make Xochimilco
more attractive as a tourist destination.
And someone had the idea
to introduce manatees
into the canals.
And what resulted was that
the manatees did not survive.
It was not the right environment for them.
It was far too cold.
But then rumors started to spread
that locals were catching
them and eating them
and making manatee tacos.
And so, I know this sounds all
really wild and preposterous,
but it was a story that
was so unfathomable
that when I heard it, I
thought it was just folklore.
And actually by doing research discovered
that it did in fact
happen though it is very,
it's a very sort of like succinct chapter
in Mexico's history and
there isn't a whole lot
written about it.
But it's an example and a really
enthralling story, I think,
about what happens when humans try to mess
with a natural environment too much.
Like you have a perfect
ecosystem, which is
this swamp, this canal area,
and you can't just introduce
whatever animal that you want
into it to make it into
some sort of a lucrative opportunity.
So, we'll see.
We're still, I'm still working on it.
There's also plenty of
other stories in the works,
but I feel like that was more up the,
sort of in line with the
callo de hacha piece.
So we'll see how it turns out.
And when I can get back to Mexico City
to do those interviews.
- I think we'd all agree
there're gonna be anybody better
to tell that story. Look forward to it.
Bring it to us.
- Well thank you.
Thank you all so much
for having me as a part of this.
It really was such a great opportunity.
- Yeah, thank you.
It was a real privilege
for us to hear from you.
Thank you so much Esther,
and here's wishing you the
best in your next adventure
and we eagerly look forward
to hearing more about it.
So behalf of Franke
program and the audience,
thanks so much for coming today.
- All right, you thank you so much.
It was a pleasure.
- Yeah. Bye bye everyone.
- Bye.